[Music]
Glenn blocked me okay yeah that was
messed up savagely blocked him it's not
the first time she's blocked me Blake is
basically trash-talking everyone you
know I don't really give a crap what
John says or does I'm here to beat him
I'm here to beat her and I'm even here
to beat Gwen
when was using the strategy like we'll
listen if you pick me you technically
you're gonna get Blake too right
that's bullcrap because I'm not gonna
help her you know look you're messing up
this interview I'm posed to say certain
things now you're making me be honest
well unless I'm drinking against the
pros right now Gwen's got a lot going on
taping the voice her Vegas show and
being a mom of three I just feel like
I'm alive in a way I've never been
before
and school started too so I got a baby
in kindergarten now and that was
devastating you know I got junior high
my god I can't believe you junior
highers meanwhile Gwen's girl Kelly is
getting a lot of love for her new talk
show and Jon's feeling a little left out
I feel like people discount the fact
that I have a talk show too though it's
called trailer talk this is episode two
we have not gotten cancelled yet don't
have a mic yet but we we are a talk show
[Music]